O
ANOTHER BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT,
OR IS IT BETTER THAT THE
CONGRESS POLICE ITS OWN?
>> AND JOINING ME NOW IS CNN
SENIOR LEGAL ANALYST AND FORMER
PRESENT FEDERAL PROSECUTOR ALI
HOMINICK --
ALI, BIG DAY TOMORROW.
AS WE ALL KNOW, WE'VE BEEN
SAYING THIS TIME AND AGAIN THE
REFERRALS ARE NOT LEGALLY
BINDING BUT HOW DO YOU THINK
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WILL
TREAT THEM IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE INVESTIGATIONS THAT THEY
ALREADY HAVE UNDERWAY AND I
SUPPOSE I'M ALSO INTERESTED IN
THE REACTION TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
HE'S KEPT HIS CARDS CLOSE TO
THE VEST FOR MANY MONTHS NOW.
>> AS YOU SAID, JIM, THESE
CRIMINAL RUFFLES ARE NOT
FINDING OUR PROSECUTORS ON
ANYWAY.
THAT SAID, I ASSURE YOU
PROSECUTORS WILL BE GOING
THROUGH THESE REFERRALS VERY,
VERY CAREFULLY.
WE KNOW THE TOYOTAS
INVESTIGATING DONALD TRUMP, WE
KNOW THAT THE DNA WAS THIS
EVIDENCE.
THEY WERE ASKING FOR PUBLICLY,
WE ARE GARLAND IN HIS LAST
PUBLIC STATEMENT MADE --
SAID PLEASE GIVE ME ALL OF THE
--
NEED A PRONUNCIATIONS.
WE ALSO, NOW TIM, THE COMMITTEE
HAS UNCOVERED PARTS OF
IMPORTANT EVIDENCE EITHER FOR
BEFORE THE DJ GOT THERE OR THAT
THEY DIDN'T HAVE.
WE KNOW THEY GOT CASSIDY
HUTCHINS TESTIMONY, HAS TO
FELONIES TESTIMONY.
THEY GOT SEVERAL --
TEXT FROM MARK MEADOWS.
IF I'M AT THE DM EAGERLY
ANTICIPATING NOT JUST THE
REFERRAL BUT THE ACTUAL
EVIDENCE ITSELF.
>> AND WHEN IT COMES TO THE
CHARGES OF BEING CONSIDERED
AGAINST TRUMP.
OBSTRUCTION OF A NO OFFICIAL
PROCEEDING, CONSPIRACY TO
DEFRAUD THE UNITED STATES, AND
INSURRECTION.
HOW HIGH IS THE BAR FOR THE
CHARGES IN A COURT OF LAW.
IS ONE THING FOR CONGRESS TO
RECOMMEND THESE CHARGES, NOW
THEY'RE FOR PROSECUTORS TO
PURSUE THEM.
>> RIGHT, TIM.
THE LEGAL TEXTBOOKS SAY THAT IN
ORDER TO INDICT A CASE ALL YOU
NEED TO DO IS SHOW PROBABLE
CAUSE.
THAT SAID, WE ALL PROSECUTORS
HAVE GUIDANCE INCLUDING THE
DAKOTA, SAYING YOU SHOULD NEVER
CHARGE A CASE IN LESS YOUR
PROOF BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT.
ULTIMATELY, THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO PROVE TO
UNANIMOUS JURY.
THAT IS THE HIGHEST JURY THE
STANDARD UNDER OUR LAWS.
THE REALITY IS IF YOU ARE
THINKING ABOUT A CHARGE AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP OR NOT THE
POWERFUL PERSON, THAT WILL GET
MORE SCRUTINY WITHIN THE OG
THEN TURNED AGAINST A NORMAL
PERSON WITHOUT QUESTION.
I THINK WHEN WE LOOK AT THESE 3
CHARGES THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY
BE VOTING ON TOMORROW,
OBSTRUCTION CONSPIRACY OUR 3RD
SORT OF NO SURPRISE.
THE DJ HAS GONE ON RECORD BUT
THE JUDGE SAYING THEY HAVE SOME
EVIDENCE OF THAT INSURRECTION,
--
THAT'S REALLY INTERESTING.
I DON'T THINK WITH THE RJ WILL
ULTIMATELY BE INTERESTED IN
THAT BECAUSE A CERTIFICATE TO
PROVE.
THAT IS A NEW SORT OF ELEMENTS
TO THE WHOLE NEXT, HERE.
>> BEYOND TRUMP, THERE ARE ALSO
CONSIDERING HOW TO HOLD
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DEFYING THEIR
SUBPOENAS DURING THE
INVESTIGATION.
THOSE LAWMAKERS, ESSENTIALLY,
THUMBED THEIR NOSE OF THE
COMMITTEE THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS.
YOU HAVE TALKED ABOUT MANY
TIMES.
YOU AND I GET A SUBPOENA, WE
COMPLY WITH THE SUBPOENA.
THESE LAWMAKERS DID NOT IN SOME
CASES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS MOST
LIKELY SCENARIO?
>> I'M NOT HOLDING A BREATH
WAITING FOR MUCH FROM THE
COMMITTEE HERE, THE REALITY IS
AS MUCH GOOD AND TOUGH WORK
THEY HAVE DONE.
THEY'VE GOT LIGHT ON THEIR
COLLEAGUES.
THERE'S NO WAY AROUND THAT.
THEY SUBPOENA KEVIN MCCARTHY,
JIM JORDAN, THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE HOUSE WHO COMPLETELY
BLEW OFF THE SUBPOENAS.
OTHER PEOPLE WHO SO DEFY THE
SUBPOENAS WERE --
FOR CRIMINAL CONTEMPT.
STEVE BANNON SERVING JAIL TIME
BECAUSE HE DID THAT.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE
CALL THEY HAVE GONE LIGHT ON
THEIR OWN COLLEAGUES.
THEY MAY REFER TO THE ETHICS
COMMITTEE OR SAM SLAP ON THE
WRIST, BUT KEVIN MCCARTHY AND
JIM JORDAN ARE GOING TO STAY
QUIET AND GET AWAY WITH IT.
>> LATE YESTERDAY WE LEARNED
THAT THE GEORGIA SPECIAL GRAND
JURY INVESTIGATED TRUMP'S
EFFORTS TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION RESULTS.
THAT'S WINDING DOWN.
IT THEY ARE NOW RIGHT IN THE
FINAL REPORT.
WHAT MORE DO YOU NEED BEYOND A
PHONE CALL OF TRUMP STRONG
ARMING THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO FIND 11,000 SOME ODD VOTES?
I KNOW YOU DON'T THINK IT'S A
SLAM DUNK, BUT THIS IS
INTERESTING THAT WE ARE GETTING
TO THE END OF THIS
INVESTIGATION AND YOU AND I
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS, THERE
ARE TRUMP FOLKS I'VE TALKED
ABOUT SPOKEN WITH WHO SAY THIS
IS ONE INVESTIGATION THEY WORRY
ABOUT.
>> YEAH, JIM, I DON'T THINK
THAT THERE IS ANY SMOKING GUN
OR A SLAM DUNK HERE.
I THINK THAT IS DONE IN
IMPORTANCE OF EVIDENCE FOR
PROSECUTORS, PROBABLY THE BEST
PIECE OF EVIDENCE THEY HAVE.
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS AN
AUTOMATIC CONVICTION, LIKE I
SAID BEFORE.
ANYBODY TRIED CASES KNOWS THAT
IT IS NEVER EASY TO PROVE
SOMEBODY'S GUILTY BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT FOR A
UNANIMOUS JURY.
NEVER MIND DONALD TRUMP, A
WIDELY LOVED AND WIDELY HEEDED.
IT MAKES IT EVEN MORE DIFFICULT
TO GET TO UNANIMITY.
I DO THINK, JIM, THAT THE SIGNS
ARE CLEAR THAT T.A.S
INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN
ACCELERATING THE PAST FEW
MONTHS.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE A DECISION
VERY, VERY QUICKLY ABOUT
WHETHER THEY DO OR DO NOT
INDICT.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO DO THAT,
CERTAINLY WITHIN THE NEXT MONTH
OR SO COMING INTO 2023.
>> ALL RIGHT, VERY GOOD.
ELIE, THANKS SO MUCH.
WE APPRECIATE THE TIME.
HAPPY HOLIDAYS.
>> ALL RIGHT, JIM.
ALL RIGHT.
>> JOIN ME NOW CNN --
APRIL, RYAN AND CNN POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR AND FORMER
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN FROM
PENNSYLVANIA, CHARLIE DENT.
APRIL, TOMORROW WE EXPECT TRUMP
TO BE REFERRED TO THE JETS
PARLIAMENT FOR CRIMINAL
CHARGES.
I MEAN, THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT
MOMENT.
WE ARE GOING TO END THE DAY
TOMORROW, EVERY NEWSPAPER IN
THE COUNTRY, ALL OF THE
NETWORKS ARE GOING TO BE
REPORTING ON THIS.
THAT IS A BIG MOMENT.
>> IT'S A HUGE MOMENT, TAKEN
FROM THE WORDS OF FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP AND AT
THE END OF THE DAY, THE JANUARY
6 COMMITTEE, --
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS WHO
COMPRISE THIS COMMITTEE,
SUSTAINABLY PUT TOGETHER
EVIDENCE LINKING WHAT THEY
BELIEVE IS DONALD TRUMP TO THE
JANUARY 6 INSURRECTION AT A
HISTORIC MOMENT.
SOME OF THE NEVER HAPPENED IN
THIS NATION'S HISTORY BEFORE
AND WHAT WE UNDERSTAND FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, TO INCLUDE
SOMEONE I TALKED TO ON IMMERSE
OCCASIONS THROUGHOUT THE COURSE
OF THIS COMMITTEE HEARING.
BENNY THOMPSON, THE HEAD OF
JANUARY 6TH SELECT COMMITTEE,
HE SAID LOOK.
HE SAID, IF NOTHING WE HAVE
PRODUCED ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO
MAKE MERRICK GARLAND LOOK HARD
AND MAYBE EVEN GO FURTHER THAN
WHAT HE HAD PLANNED TO BECAUSE
OF THIS.
IT IS WHAT HE SAID, WE HAVE
PUSHED HIM TO FURTHER LOOK AND
MAYBE ACT.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS HAPPENED.
WE KNOW THAT THERE WILL BE
RECOMMENDATIONS, BUT WHAT'S
NEXT AFTER THAT?
THAT'S THE ISSUE.
>> RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ALL WAITING
TO FIND OUT.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
CHARLIE, SO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED HIS
PRESIDENTIAL BID ABOUT MORE
THAN, GO HE HAS DINED WITH
ANTISEMITES, HE SAID YOU WANT
TO DETERMINATE THE
CONSTITUTION.
THERE WERE THOSE NEARLY FOUND
CLASSIFY DOCUMENTS.
THE LIST GOES ON.
HOW WOULD A CRIMINAL REFERRAL
TO THE D OJ FROM THE CONGRESS,
FROM THE GENERAL 6 COMMITTEE,
IMPACT HIS CANDIDACY, DO YOU
THINK?
IT'S NOT GOING TO AFFECT THE
BASE, IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE IT?
>> I'M NOT SURE SO SURE HOW
MUCH THE ACTUAL REFERRAL YOU
MEAN TO HIS CANDIDACY, BUT WHAT
WILL MATTER IS WHETHER THE
CHARGE IT ACTUALLY BRINGS
CHARGES AGAINST FORMER
PRESIDENT, I WOULD THINK THAT
HAS AN ENORMOUS IMPACT ON HIS
CANDIDACY.
--
HIS VOTERS, HIS BASE VOTERS
HAVE BEEN WILLING TO OVERLOOK
AND FORGIVE A LOT OF SINS, BUT
THE CRIMINAL RUFFLE IF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WERE TO BE
INDICTED, THAT WOULD BE A
BRIDGE TOO FAR FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
CERTAINLY THAT WAS ON THE EDGES,
WHO --
ARE MORE CRAZY ABOUT HIS
PERSONALITY OR CONDUCT.
I THINK THAT WOULD FURTHER
DRIVE THEM AWAY AND SEEMS THAT
HE IS A DIFFERENT MENACED
FIGURE IN SO MANY WAYS.
HE HAS BEEN DIMINISHING FOR
SOMETIME, EVEN BEFORE THE MOST
RECENT ELECTION HE HAS BEEN
DIMINISHED THING.
HE IS STILL A DANGEROUS FIGURE,
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
IT IS FOR THE WEEKEND AND --
INDICTMENT.
>> APRIL, I HAVE TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THIS.
WHAT TRUMP WOULD CALL A MAJOR
ANNOUNCEMENT TURNED TO NOT BE
SO MAJOR.
IT TURNED OUT TO BE AN NFT FOR
DIGITAL TRADING CARDS.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
>> MY OFFICIAL TRUMP DIGITAL
TRADING CARDS ARE 99 DOLLARS,
WHICH DOESN'T SOUND LIKE VERY
MUCH FOR WHAT YOU ARE GETTING.
I WANT THAT YOU'LL JOY EVERY
NAME EXCLUSIVE COMMUNITY, MY
COMMUNITY.
I THINK SOMETHING YOU ARE GOING
TO LIKE AND LIKE IT A LOT.
>> APRIL, THAT PROMPTED THIS
NOT SO IMPRESSED REACTION FROM
2 OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
CLOSEST ALLIES.
LET'S WATCH THAT.
>> WHOEVER --
BUSINESS PARTNER AND ANYBODY IN
THE KONSTANTIN ORNATELY MARLAR
GO, THEY'RE A LOT OF FOLKS DOWN
THERE.
WE ARE AT WAR.
THEY OUGHT TO BE FIRED, TODAY.
>> IT NEVER SHOULD'VE HAPPENED.
I MEAN, IT'S FUN, IT'S
HYPERBOLIC, BUT WHOEVER WROTE
THAT PITCH SHOULD BE FIRED AND
NEVER BE INVOLVED IN ANY --
I DON'T WANT THEM MAKING THE
PRESIDENTIAL OF NAPKINS FOR
MARA LAGO.
>> APRIL, WHEN YOU'VE LOST
STEVE BANNON --
APRIL, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT?
>> OH.
>> SHE FROZE.
--
CHARLIE --
>> I'LL TELL YOU, ON THAT --
>> I'M HERE!
I'M HERE!
>> GO AHEAD.
>> APRIL, GO AHEAD.
>> YEAH, LET ME SAY THIS.
STEVE BANNON AND DONALD TRUMP
HAVE BEEN CLOSED FOR MANY YEARS
AND WHEN THEY COULDN'T TALK
TOGETHER, THEY WERE TALKING
THROUGH THEIR LAWYERS.
NOW HERE IS THE PIECE.
DONALD TRUMP IS NOW MORE OF A
CHARACTER OF HIMSELF THAN HE
EVER WAS, BEFORE HE IS NOW
PLAYING TO THE BASE THAT
BELIEVES HE IS THE HERO.
HE IS PLAYING TO THE BASE THAT
THINKS HE COULD DO NOTHING
WRONG.
THAT THIS IS THE WORST THING TO
DO IN THIS MOMENT AND STEVE
BANNON IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
HE NEEDS TO BE WORKING ON
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN NEXT AND HOW TO
LAWYER UP AND LEVEL UP.
THIS IS A SERIOUS MOMENT.
SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS AND IT'S
NOT TIME TO PLAY SUPERHERO
DIGITALLY OR COMIC BOOK WISE,
EITHER WAY.
>> YEAH, CHARLIE, I'M GUESSING
YOU DIDN'T MAKE ANY PURCHASES
OF THESE TUSSLE TRADING CARDS.
FEEL FREE TO CORRECT THE
RECORD.
>> I MOST CERTAINLY DID NOT I
AGREE WITH APRIL.
THIS IS --
THE FORMER PRESIDENT SEEM SO
UNSERIOUS HERE.
HE SEEMS LIKE A HUCKSTER.
UNBECOMING OF HIS OFFICE.
VAN, AND I DON'T NORMALLY AGREE
WITH STEVE BANNON, BUT HE'S
RIGHT.
THESE ARE SERIOUS TIMES ON THIS
FORMER PRESIDENT IS FACING VERY
SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS.
TO PUSH THESE DIGITAL TRADING
CARDS WITH THIS BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT, IT REALLY FURTHER
DIMINISHES DONALD TRUM